all right for more than a year the
housing market has been booming and
finding affordable homes will be hard
very very difficult so now people are
looking to buy are investing in modular
homes also known as mobile homes mary
jane bellissa explains how these homes
could reshape the housing industry
flamingo west here on flamingo and
cimarron is just one of the many mobile
home communities appealing to potential
home buyers all with the choice of
amenities customization and
affordability in an oversaturated
housing market mobile homes are helping
cut costs ted cooper says it's helped
him he's had his mobile home for two
years now compared to a stick built home
is a fraction of the cost the taxes are
cheaper the lots are usually smaller so
the maintenance is a lot less and and
it's a nice area i compared the cost of
some mobile home parks in the valley
depending on the year and size of the
home costs can run anywhere from thirty
thousand for a one bedroom one bath in
el dorado estates or up to a hundred and
fifty thousand for a three bedroom and
mountain view mobile home park andre
alpha owns vegas mobile homes he says 70
percent of the buyers choose these homes
because it fits their finances the need
for quality and affordable housing has
never been greater than it is right now
especially with how overheated the
housing market is
right now we're seeing more and more
people shift away from conventional
site-built homes and explore
manufactured homes as an option jean
parrott has managed el dorado state's
mobile home park since 1996 she adds the
process of traditional home buying goes
beyond four walls a lot of people
don't realize that these are not the
trailer homes of yesteryear these are
homes that in some cases look better
than site built home because they have
the quality control during the building
process that some site build homes just
don't have reporting from flamingo and
cimarron mary jane balleza live local
now